so we understand that you have some very
strong tips on how to not just get in
the business but stay there you talk to
a lot of actors yeah I would consult
actors beginning actors in New York
someone would be like how did you do
this how did you get the jay-z
commercial how did you get an agent how
did you and I would give them tips you
know but the first tip is this go get
good at acting go take a class go take
multiple classes go do improv just go
get good at acting because that's how
you're going to book work you're going
to go into the room and you're going to
kill an audition and that's where you're
gonna book work unless you're a
ridiculously looking good-looking person
and you just go in and just someone
wants to sleep with you and yeah you're
going to book work doing that too but if
you really want to be a working actor in
this business
go get good so call the best teachers
call the best acting coaches and go work
on your craft the next thing is go be
marketable meaning present yourself in a
marketable way get an acting actor reel
it when you have footage how do you get
footage if you don't have an agent or a
manager go do student films this is a
perfect opportunity to go practice what
you're working on and actually the
pressure is low to know it's like you do
a student film and you don't do well in
it guess who's going to watch it nobody
okay the students are going to watch it
so go practice your craft doing you know
independent stuff a lot of people it
just irks me when people like oh that's
a student feel I'm not going to do that
you're not oh oh really you're not going
to because who are you again like who
are you like some like working actor who
can turn down work no you're going to do
that student film because you're not a
good actor or maybe you are good actor
but you still need the practice
do not turn down work it's an
opportunity you should be grateful there
are millions of actors out there who
don't do who don't work at all
you know that student film that was off
to you that role make the most of it try
something new you know take risks oh god
I just get frustrated sometimes with
actors who say they're actors and they
are turning down work because it's
there's no money there's no money in the
beginning there is no money you're not
doing this for money you're doing this
because you love it and you want to get
better and it's inspirational you're not
doing it because you know the student
film only pays you $50 a day give me a
break
even that $50 day - what - act awesome
ah anyway so yeah tips so go get a good
acting coach go get better at acting do
student films you know to make stuff for
your reel what else and surround
yourself surround yourself with artistic
people who are like you and love love
the art because if you surround yourself
with people who are I have to like our
like-minded as you you're going to get
better I probably have I can say four or
five actor friends and all of them have
the same blue so I do about acting and
it's it's we do it or we die it's like I
want to do this for the rest of my life
or there's not that no other option and
that's I don't know when we're and
they're creative and brilliant and you
want to surround yourself with people
who are better than you or more talented
with you than you because then you get
better you rise to their level and yeah
there's a lot of actors I look up to and
I aspire to be like
you